From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Where do you roll?
Okay.
Today is Saturday March 9, 2013.
My name is Willie Griffin and I am a research associate with the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I am with videographer John Bishop and Albany Georgia on the campus of Albany State University to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here today with Mr. Sam Young, Jr.
Thank you so much for being here Mr. Young and agreeing to share your story with us on the Civil Rights History Project.
Thank you.
All right. So I just want to begin first off by having you stay to full name and tell when and where to go.
Okay. My name is Sam Young, Jr.
And I was born in Worth County, Sylvester, Georgia.
March 13, 1950.
Okay. March 13, 1950.
So what was it like growing up in 1950, you were right on the cusp of the Brown vs. Board of Education.
What else is going on in the civil rights movement?
In the 1950s growing up, I was very aware of certain issues like the Board of Education thing.
And my father, he was very political and he always kept us abreast on different issues.
But I did not understand what that was all about during when he was telling me about it.
What was your father's name?
About the Board of Education.
Your father's name was Sam Young, Jr.
Right, right. He was Sam Young, Jr.
And he was very influential in the political scene.
And he always kept us abreast about different political issues that were going on around us.
Okay.
And he made us watch the news every day.
And when I really understood my after I became older and had some of the issues faced me, you know, head on.
And then I understood a lot of things that he would be speaking of.
So like for example, in Worth County, did you experience any of the signs of racism or...
Oh, growing up in Worth County?
Yes, especially during our school integration.
Okay.
You know, because when I went to, at that time, it was Freedom of Choice.
You know, you had, you know, if you wanted to go, you know, that was one of the, I guess, one of the things that they did to keep people from actually...
Right.
So you had the opportunity to go to a white school if you did, but you could remain in a all black school if you wanted to.
Okay.
And lots of my friends, you know, they did exactly that.
But I chose to go to the, with Freedom of Choice, things chose to go to the other schools, the white schools.
And when I started school, we, our schools were out with our churches in Worth County.
And we were walked every day back and forth, you know, to school.
And the school buses would come by.
And as I remember, the children, you know, what hang the heads out of the window, when they're calling us, or racial names and all that.
But we, the bus would always meet at the paths in the woods were always clear" when we got out of school, we would always be exactly about the same place.
And you know, little kids, you know, when somebody's messing with you, you know, we threw rocks at the bus, you know.
I mean, that's what we did.
And the bus driver would put the lights on, you know, brake lights.
We see the brake lights come out.
Right.
And back in those days, they were during what they called turpentine time, you know, where they get the bus straight to the tree and get the, what they call gum.
And they would make a lot of our products out of that.
And the, the, the, the, the, the paths in the woods were always clear".
And we just try to get through with, maybe they'd never be able to catch them.
You know, and I, when I went to school, when we, when they did build schools in Worse County, my father said that I could not read.
And I had a sister coming into the first grade, the same time, at that same time.
I support them in the second grade.
And we went through school together, you know.
And everybody thought we were twins, but we're not.
My father kept me back because he said I could not read.
And I'm very glad that he did that because I probably could look at some of my grandchildren sometimes.
And even my own kids, you know, I knew they, they would not qualify, you know, to read.
And I'm glad he cared about that.
And I had the kind of teachers that you, you, you didn't escape.
There was no net.
You had to get your lesson.
Right. You know, and, and you had to, you, there was no cheating.
And you weren't just going to disappear in the back of the class.
Oh, no.
That was not going to happen.
And once I remember, I, I always tell my grandkids this story, you know, about trying to cheat.
I was caught sitting on a spelling book.
And the teacher came back to me, she said, young, are you cheating?
And I said, no.
She said, well, stand up.
And when I stood up, you know, the spelling book right there.
And I, and she spanked me.
And then I remember, you know, getting, you know, I guess, you know, upset and say, well, you know, I'm going to tell my father, you know, I'm going to tell my mother.
And at those days, you know, she said, come on, let's go.
I'll take you to her because we can see who's right.
I really didn't want that to happen.
You're a posture.
But that's that's some of the things that happen.
And when the schools integrated, you know, I'm under the impression that, you know, okay, the white people are way smarter.
I'm going into with this expectation, you know, and I had her.
It was a very awakening experience, you know, and then when you let one other thing that my parents told me, you never follow the crowd.
You were born and individual and you would die and individually.
And that's one that I do that even today.
Even though some issues might be, you know, if I decide to go along, is that we, if just that's a universal thing, that everything is, you know, good.
And I go along, but if I got some issues with it, I would not do it.
And just because of the group.
And we had several incidents of racist, racial things to happen.
They came out to our church, some kids, you know, just basically kids doing things, you know, and they, they are painted the front of our church.
It's the same church that I grew up at and you know, went to school and all that.
What was the name of the church?
Blue spraying Baptist church in Worth Church.
Okay.
And so they painted some things on it.
The church black and said written that this is the devil's den or something of that.
But we found out there was one of the local vendors, some that did it.
And he made him go back out and repaint the whole thing, you know, because of what he had did.
And we had some other incidents, you know, matter of fact, my cousins, two of my cousins were taken into custody at Worth County High School because she, she and the white guy got into it and she beat him.
They came and arrested her, right off the school bus and they took them, brought them over. They went to Worth County.
They brought them over to Albany at the Youth Detention Center here.
And the sheriff would not tell my aunt where those kids were.
Was this pressure? Was this still a pressure in Albany?
No, no, this was.
Oh, the sheriff was.
I think it was at that time, I believe it was a pressure. Well, it was about to one day.
Okay.
I'm not sure what they were related.
But at the time, Attorney C.B. King was a very prominent black lawyer here.
And they are.
It was only the children were out of place for three days before the sheriff would tell.
He would not, my aunt went down to the, they would not tell her where her children were.
Your cousins can't be any more than 14, maybe, maybe?
Somewhere in that neighborhood.
And they took her to those two kids.
And C.B. threatened to have the sheriff arrested.
And at that point, he told whether the children were, and they were over here in Albany.
But beforehand, beforehand, they would not release the location of whether the children were.
And it was kind of scary because we were young.
And when somebody takes a, some part of your family, and nobody's telling you where they are,
and understanding some of the issues that would black people going on all over the country, especially in the South,
we were some of the children that, they might be, you know, disincent of something.
And they're not just the police.
Yeah.
So that was that.
And I have seen a lot, not seen, but I have been in the presence of a lot of things.
I even have some people that were shot because they were trying to break up a fight.
And that was a guy that came out and just, you know, shot him.
You know, just because, you know, I guess, you know, he was the white guy.
And you were a school age at this time?
I was a school age, you know, you're doing the time right.
All these things are happening.
Lots of things happen.
Then once, you know, I remember my father was a Sunday school teacher also.
And I remember one of the deacons, one of my, you know, kids we all grew up in our trade family.
And he came to work, not to work, but to have been to work.
And he got shot.
The guy that he was working for.
The son of that, his employee, wanted him to call him.
This man was probably three times his son because he was a teenager.
But he wanted him to call him the young guy wanted him to call him Mr.
So he said, no, I'm not going to call you Mr.
And so the father, he went to the father and told the father about it.
And the father without asking the, my friend's nose father, anything about he just came out with his shotgun.
Wow.
And the only reason, I always remember, I couldn't understand how another human being could do such things to one another.
But he got shot.
And the only reason that he didn't get blinded or killed was he threw his hands up, you know, as a shield.
And I remember in our Sunday school, he was telling about the story.
And you know, the buckshot, you know, he had all the, you know, the pellets and stuff, where they, you know, penetrated skin and in his face, you know.
So he would have been blinded.
He was aiming for his head.
Yeah.
And he just, he was some turbotimes.
He was some turbotimes.
And things may have changed.
And they may not have taken.
Do you remember this guy's name and all of them who got shot?
His name was Albert Gill.
Albert Gill.
Oh, the one that got shot?
Yeah.
Oh, no, his name was CT Rockwell.
CT Rockwell.
And Albert Gill was who?
The shooter.
Okay.
No, right.
Yeah.
But sometimes, you know, I think back, I have some embedded hatred for, you know, sometimes.
But as I grow older, I look at things.
And even though there was some, a lot of things, you know, directed, you know, the racial thing directed towards my father,
because they were like, they were black land on us.
Right.
And loans were foreclosed, you know, everything, you know.
And I remember there was a local white grocer that he also had a hardware store.
And he extended my father a line of credit, you know, to farm with.
And that's how we made it through those times.
And we, he, my father, ran and I profit to him for years.
I never understood it.
But after he quit farming, you know, but see, performing for young black men, you know, and for the farm, you know, the land in order to be passed on to the black people.
There was nothing, you know, there was no, and then I look at now, even the farmers around us.
And their kids, generations of them, you know, the land and the farming business has passed on and on on to them.
But, you know, there was no such thing for black people.
And just recently, I guess, there are a lot of opportunities, you know, after the, the, the, oh man, the ASCS (Agricultural Stabilization and Conservation Service) office of,
they got to, they changed it to Farm Service Agency now.
And there's a lot of things out there that are, you know, good for, you know, young black farmers.
But I think, you know, we went through an era where, you know, farm was work.
We don't, we don't want to put out that camera.
And you learned it from your father.
Right. I grew up on the farm.
Okay. Right.
And I was up, what were some of the things you planted?
I was planted cotton, corn, peanuts, vegetables, squash, butter beans, peas, okra.
And then I was, we were the one, our children, you know, I'm from a large family.
And how many brothers and sisters?
I have 10 sisters. I had 10 sisters and they were seven brothers.
And I, I see, when I think about it, you know, we had the large family because we were going to be the ones
to, to together the crops and everything, which was bad because I learned a lot of experiences about work.
You know, and I was the oldest son and I had two sisters that were older than I am.
And we all graduated from our schools and were in our, in our county.
You know, when the odds were, well, basically, you know, I guess, you know, you're receiving a pretty good education.
I just, you know, I'm receiving a diploma.
Yeah.
And I graduated, I was the only in 1968.
It was when I graduated.
And I think as I remember, I might have been the only, like, male, you know, in that group.
It's a class, you know, it's probably about four or five, like, ladies.
What was the name of the school of high school you graduated from?
Our Worth County High School in Sylvester, Georgia.
So, and you graduated in 1968.
Sixth grade.
Sixth grade, that was a, really critical time.
Sixth grade, I suppose, very, very critical.
The civil rights movement is supposedly ended in the Black Power movement emerges.
But that was, that was...
That's the positive thing.
The art history is full.
We don't want this.
Okay.
That were taken out the births were my first cousins, dark, the young, and Yvonne young.
That's good.
All right.
So, we'll go back to 1968 and you're graduating.
Again, this is a really critical time in African-American history.
Yeah.
1968 are...
I graduated.
And after high school...
My first public job that I had was...
That was Firestone Tire Tire here.
And that's what...
That was my first job.
And I ran into some pretty tough civil rights problems.
So, I changed...
I didn't...
They let me go along with some other people.
And then I found out about the...
I had two older sisters that were working with the Southwest Georgia Project for Community Education.
Could you...
I'm sorry, before you move.
Could you just talk about those supervisors at Firestone Tire...
Oh, they were...
They were...
They were mean.
And I'm working.
You know, I'm working...
I'm breaking a terrible sweat.
Right.
And right out of the high school, you know, I'm thinking I'm...
That's when I realized that I need some more education because...
When I got out...
And I went on the job site.
They were building the...
You know, the farming, the building that was going to have some heavy...
The machine sitting there, you know, the time machine that...
Okay.
That's going to be a little time.
And so, they were...
the foundations were way down, you know, like in the ground.
You had to climb down there in the ladder, you know, and bust the...
The farms up around the concrete.
Okay.
So, I was thinking, well, you know, I'm educated.
I got a high school degree, you know, but I'm...
I'm going to be doing something.
They gave me a picnic chair.
And I had to go down there.
And it was terrible, but I was working, but they...
I guess I wasn't...
Meeting that criteria.
Something.
And then I worked with the Southwest Georgia Project from like 19...
up until 1983.
Okay.
I went to school because we had...
We said we're going to start a newspaper, you know,
and I went to Albany Technical College to learn graphic art, you know,
running machines and everything.
And the farming is what I will.
I grew up with it.
It's hard work, but it pays off, you know, when you do it right.
And so, I worked mostly with the farm part.
Could you tell us what the Southwest Georgia Project was?
I mean, when you...
It was a community education group, you know,
and it covered the Southwest Georgia area.
We had people, you know, in all of counties that would come here.
And it also had a scholarship program,
which sent a lot of people to, you know, different college...
Got scholarship for them and things like that.
Was this how you got into Albany Technical College?
Did you get a scholarship through the Southwest Georgia Project?
Oh, yes, but...
Okay.
So, who was that when the first people in the project that, you know,
sort of showed you the roads,
where did you work on, and where did you work with?
I worked basically on the Charles Sherrod,
and there were other people.
Some of them have deceased, has been, you know, since then.
One of them was a Randolph Battle.
I don't know. He was a good mentor of mine.
And I was young, you know,
these guys like took me on the day.
Wayne has taught me a whole lot of things.
And another one was Robert Mants.
And he was another one that, you know,
they took me in and taught me a lot of things about,
you know, politics and you know,
how to handle things and all that.
You know, I took it in.
Because I was all ears, you know.
I took it in.
And, you know,
I met, past maybe a couple of years ago.
Well, nothing, not quite a couple of years.
And we talked, and he had heart attack.
But, you know, you're talking,
we're talking about things that happened.
And it was amazing that, you know,
the kind of, where we have basically kind of reached a conclusion on a lot of things.
You know, we were seeing basically down the road together on that.
And I'm not sure whether you all are familiar with attorney Mary Young.
Attorney at that name sounds familiar.
You could talk a little bit about that.
She was a major champion for the civil rights movement in this area.
Okay.
And she defended a lot of people, you know,
black and white.
And she also, she counted a lot of diverse,
both cases and different things like that.
And she also, she worked as a,
she came in on the attorney C.B. King when she first came to all many.
You know, I think I met her last year.
You forgiven me, right?
Okay.
She was a real person.
No real.
Okay.
So, let's talk about school then, you know, for the graphic arts.
Oh, graphic art, you know, it is, it's a,
it's the printing, you're going to learn to run the printing presses.
You learn to do the graphics like on this book, you know, pictures and stuff like that.
And then you, you know, you do the plates, the negatives,
and you take it to the machine and you run them.
And then, you know, type said, you know, you set the columns,
all that, you know, you learn something that,
but I never could do that because my hands were so...
So, I couldn't do that.
So, I always got somebody, you know, to do that.
Okay.
So, talk about, I guess, when you, the Southwest Georgia project,
when you got involved in farming and in the project,
you know, the Southwest Georgia project.
You know, and that's how I got involved in it.
The Southwest Georgia project, New Communities Inc,
which was the land, it was a project, all of the Southwest Georgia project.
You know, and that's how I got involved in it.
We found my, uh, Sherrod went to, uh, New York and found out that the land
was for sale, or heel in, um, in Southwest Georgia.
Southwest Georgia.
But, uh, nobody, you know, it wasn't posted,
but he found out about it who had been, uh, New York.
Okay.
And, uh, he pursued the idea to the point where, you know,
it was, uh, it was, uh, it was, uh, the idea was to,
to purchase this huge tract of land and become, you know, self sufficient,
for black communities, you know, for new communities, okay?
And your role in this, when, when you find,
when did you finally secure the land?
And it had to be in, uh, 68.
Okay.
1968.
So, you were just graduating.
I was out of, I was right out of, I was out of, I was out of,
and, but I still was a member of the Southwest Georgia Project, you know,
and I just remembered, you know.
And, that was good.
We did a lot of things, and also we have a lot of our students come down
from different states, you know, a lot of youth,
a lot of youth was involved into it.
And it was a great thing.
It would, it would have been even greater.
Uh, but in, uh, 70s,
um, if, if, uh, if, uh, the, uh, ASCS, you know, they, they,
they foclosed on a lot of, uh, a lot of black farmers in the area.
Okay.
You know, and, um, that's basically, uh, what happened, you know, so how long?
I mean, let's back up, you said these children were coming to the farms and, you know,
people from the, uh, you know, like we come to our town to get a bunch of children
to go out, you know, and learn about farming, you know, how to produce, uh,
your own food, you know, and, and, uh, pick it, you know, take it to the market, you know,
or prepare it for, you know, for the youth and your freedom, stuff like that.
And so you're finally getting to do what you're going to do now, right?
You're showing your skills, right?
That's the basic idea.
And then, uh, we had, uh, uh, about the money crop was the, uh, peanut crop, you know,
we had, uh, on that farm that was an allotment of, uh, over 300 some acres, you know, uh, uh,
peanut.
And we had, uh, corn, we never did plant cotton.
I don't understand.
Well, we never did.
I probably don't understand.
Nobody wanted to plant the cotton.
It, it never happened, right?
You know, but we had, uh, corn, uh, vegetables, you know, okra, you know,
lots of different things, watermelons, you know, you know, okay, and stuff like that.
We would have to take them to market.
But, uh, during the time of, and, and, well, you know, I'm, uh, are you, uh,
familiar with the, uh, suit that, uh, no, take, take us to that.
Uh, so, uh, that was, uh, when they, when they did, uh, class action suit, you know,
the government against the, uh, I guess, AS, ASCS, or, you know, over the federal government
finally admitted that there was discrimination against, uh, black farmers, okay.
And, uh, we came on a class action suit, right?
And, but it was years and years and years before anything, actually, it,
it got any, uh, monetary, uh, uh, value from that, you know.
So, but by then it was too late, you really lost the farm.
Right, we had to buy some, I think, uh, well, Shirley Sherrod and (Charles) Sherrod,
you know, who bought some, they bought a new, plot of land here in, in (likely) Doherty.
And they got a lot of things going on.
Okay.
With that now.
Mm-hmm.
They got a lot of like two years and three years.
Excuse me.
It wasn't like two years or three years.
The, uh, the suit, how long did it take to materialize?
Uh,
it was denied, uh, it had to be,
sometime in the late 80s and maybe mid 90s.
Okay.
But the final thing came through in 20, 2009, 2009.
So it was sometime between, exactly.
It was long, long time.
Long time, I mean, everybody basically had given,
given up on, uh, receiving, or anything, you know.
And I think they, they had, uh,
disqualified, uh,
as a farm, because of all the other activities that we were doing, you know,
for the, uh, community and all the other, other ongoing projects we had gone.
But, uh, eventually, you know, it came under, you know,
a new ruling, uh, I keep, I can't, uh,
maybe Charlotte or (Charles) Sherrod could tell you a lot more about it.
Okay.
I've forgotten, you know, lots of this stuff.
Yeah, I understand.
Um, could you, I'm trying to get a, a good vision of what the,
what this farm looked like and, and what you lost.
You mentioned you had 300 acres of peanuts with it.
Okay.
Um, what else?
It was, uh, dwellings out there.
Matter of fact, I lived, uh, there, from,
I got married in 74 and, uh, moved my, uh, wife and my children.
We moved on to the, uh, on-site.
Right.
And there were several other people, you know,
also moved out.
Some of them were self-adjointed projects, and some people from a local community, you know.
And, uh, we were the ones to, uh, you know, operate, you know, the farm
and I had to do all that.
So were there homes already on the farm?
Right.
There were existing homes.
So you didn't do any extra building.
No.
Okay.
We didn't, didn't, didn't exist that long, you know, but all that was, uh, in the, uh,
planning, um, but we never could get any, uh, phones or something, you know,
just to start that going.
Okay.
Then we always denied, you know, these were, you know, uh,
the 1960s, you know, and anytime that, um,
Black folk got, so you had, had, had control of something that was going to seem like, uh,
better that live, you know, you just was not taken kindly by the, the locals and, uh,
I guess, some more, other people are higher up, you know.
Yeah.
So that's what happened.
Okay.
So since the project ended, what, what have you, what have you been doing?
What has you, what have I been doing?
Okay.
I've been kind of, um, uh, just, you know, maintaining, you know, um, I need to get back
involved, you know, because there's just too many things, you know, that needs to be done.
And in other words, uh, well, I kind of got the, uh, this is just, you know,
somewhere, you know, but, uh, there's a lot of things that I, I know that needs to have on
it.
And I know I got a lot of potential, you know, to put input that I can put into, uh,
some things, you know, because I look at, uh, the situation with our black youth, you
know, there were things that, you know, we could be doing to make a difference, you know,
here in Southwest Georgia, and probably, you know, over the nation, you know,
because we had students coming from, uh, New York, Chicago, you know, so you think you
got a lot of your disappointment was stemmed from the first ball losing the phone.
Exactly.
And after decades of finally, uh, just seeing right it, I mean, with, uh, when they finally
made the decision to die.
Right.
And I may have probably, uh, eventually, um, I saw one of the Mr. Sharal, uh, that's how I got
directed to her.
She was leaving out, and I guess it just coincided that the lady was coming out of the
park a lot, not asking her where, where everything, and that was where I hadn't seen her in
over two years.
That's to show you, you know, I think, go, you know, so that was kind of like an inspiration
to me, you know, to, uh, you know, get back involved with, you know, things.
So you think that that's your next step?
You're going to get back in, okay?
So, um, I guess the legacy of the, of the Southwest Georgia project, I mean, it's still
there.
Right.
It's still there.
It never, you know, as a, it never, it never, it never deceased.
Yeah.
It never, uh, died out.
It was always there.
You know, it was not inactive to the point that it always was something going on, you know,
with it, you know, but I wasn't in the, uh, in the, you know, I kind of, you know, went
my own, uh, on separate way.
Okay.
Is there anything else you think you might want to share that we should know about your experiences
the Southwest Georgia project?
Um, any words of wisdom that you'd like to, uh, where is the wisdom?
I would say, uh, sometimes, you know, you have to be, you have to stand up sometimes,
you know, because if you don't, you know, some decision can take, take, take you to the
left or too far to the right.
But you have to, you know, in other words, address the issues, address it then.
Don't wait, uh, to later.
Okay.
You know, do it then.
And then if it still goes that way, at least you would have made your, you know, your,
had your presentation about your discontent or whatever about situation, you know.
Okay.
And that's all right.
All right.
So let me go.
How long will you talk?
About three hours?
Yeah, it's about three hours.
Oh, so Mr. Young, there was a lot more.
But uh, you, I'm sure that if you want to, yeah, we have time.
I mean, what's the outside, I thought you also let me go.
You know, you were good.
You were good.
But then you said there was a lot more.
Yeah.
No.
But you know, um,
and I, I, I, I, I guess I'm very on, uh, being coming involved with the, uh,
software project, you know, I, we're able to go, you'll see a lot of things, you know,
that I know that other kids, my age, you know, had not seen how they would go to New York City.
Uh, the, you know, the Carolinas, lots of places, you know, and I learned also a lot of
things there.
You know, and that was a part of the project.
They would take you around to places to strategically learn.
They would, there are, there were different organizations that would, uh,
send, you know, for, for, you know, for people to come up and, uh, do some things,
you know, teach different programs and stuff, different seminars.
And I got, I got, I got a chance to get in on a lot of that.
And if I want to, you know, uh, New York, that was a thing called, uh,
Synectics, you know, where you, they, what they, what they do, they teach you about,
uh, solving problems and, uh, you know, in groups and stuff, they take you in,
just like, this is like I'm sitting here talking now.
And, uh, they have you on camera.
And then they give you a whole lot of scenarios and, and you come up with the best one,
you know, to get the, what they were doing with, they, they were developing,
uh, communication skills, you know, and how to do different things, how to solve different problems.
And, uh, I went through that.
And that was, uh, the first time I saw myself on camera.
So that was interesting.
That was very interesting.
I love a lot.
And then you spoke to bring it back, bring that, what you learn back to your group,
you know, and try to implement some of the, uh, things, you know,
solve problems, solve it and things that are facing you, you know,
apply that, what you learn from, from those, uh, from their teachings.
You know, a lot of it.
And, it's a lot, but it's coming back, but, uh, you have to do me again.
You know, we do want to thank you for, uh, for coming, for coming and sharing your stories.
And, well, if there is an opportunity that you find that you want to share,
we would definitely be with you.
But I'm, I'm very happy to tell Maulil, microcarging of the story, you know,
and hope it means something to someone.
And, uh, hope some of it can be passed on, you know,
so I'm very happy to have been a part of this.
And I really thank you for this book of it here.
This, this is the kind of stuff that I like.
So now this is mine, I put it in my bag.
Thank you, game, Mr. Y.
Okay, thank you all.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.